the guy you know his mom picks the wife
for him kind of thing and you know the
guy is a very nice kid he's an obedient
kid
he's gonna say yes mom the way they have
to understand is that
okay i will obey my parents and my
parents might be happy now
but within two years if things don't
work out
the consequences of my decision are
going to hurt my parents
are going to hurt me and are going to
hurt that woman
ask people do your homework
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of people have this misconception
that uh you know once i feel closer to
god then i'm going to start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith where he says that the
most beloved acts of worship to god are
those which he made obligatory
the person continues to get closer and
closer to allah key point gets closer
and
closer
by voluntary acts of good so like
certain things you know for the sake of
allah
things that are not obligatory but you
do them just to please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
allah you want allah to love you
do what allah uh prescribes for you
which is
so praying fasting
and then on top of that sunnah prayers
uh suddenly fasts
giving extra charity to the point where
allah will insha allah begin to love you
and welcome back to the three the three
the three ones
the i'm on this thing
we're keeping it we're not gonna get you
all right all right welcome back
to this three muslims part three muslim
we're your hosts fired romney and angel
we're joined again with our honorable
guest brother gabriel romani
we're the realest what we're this
podcast in the dunya
bro how could you miss the main part bro
man i just finished
okay man
you didn't even say realist you said we
list
you know the drive fast and getting you
bro yeah man let's get into this
villa yes welcome back to the podcast we
are the realest podcast in the dunya and
we're joined again
for part four the intimacy series with
brother gabriel as romani salaam wales
you guys are about to finish huh uh-huh
yeah oh yeah
nice how are you guys feeling and the
first day was like tough man my head was
like
bro second day was the worst for me
really
yeah second day like i just felt out of
it
but today i feel i feel sh oh it's just
now that it's like now that i'm at the
end and my body is like all right bro
it's time
this time somehow it's like your body
kicks in those the extra energy you know
running towards the end they feel like
stronger
keep busy though alhamdulillah
it's good man day five today man wow
it's like flying
yeah subhanallah really is uh this is
definitely my
hardest day for me though as you can see
so we ended off uh part three or episode
three of the intimacy series talking
about preparation for nikah
so i think we should continue that insha
allah so
yeah so if you have a mental note of
where you want to start insha'allah
if not then i have a few questions
already yeah let's start with some
questions
and get you guys more involved
so in being prepared for it
we talked about financials and and all
of that building up to being ready and
all that
uh did we talk about vetting
we did a bit about vetting but uh yeah i
think we need to get a bit more into
that
yeah yeah so let's let's talk about
vetting a little bit more insha'allah
for both men and women is it similar is
a different
so yes last night i got a question from
one of my uh
clients and they were basically this was
a woman and she was basically saying
like look
like i need to get married but like how
do i go about she's like i'm terrified
and there's this gammaphobia right it's
a fear of marriage right
it's kind of like you guys it sounds
like game phobia or something but
it's called gammaphobia it's the phobia
of marriage like it's something so real
that people are scared
of marriage and she said basically like
everywhere i look is divorce divorce
divorce divorce divorce divorce everyone
is divorced i think
one of my clients was saying like of all
the friends that they have
like i think it was like 80 are divorced
within like
the first five years you know and this
is just that person's experience but
it is something that is is a problem and
of course it's not
vetting or wrong vetting is not the only
problem
there's a lot of other factors but if as
we're talking about vetting i think
our ummah the muslim ummah
we are not vetting correctly and what do
we mean by vetting meaning just
before marriage like making a decision
because you know sometimes we use these
uh western terms and people
uh might think that what are we doing
are we are we
in are we injecting something into islam
no
the concept of picking your spouse or
picking you know
your wife your husband is something very
much from the
quran sunnah from the prophet sallallahu
salaam and the first evidence for that
is
the sahaba they said to the process i'm
like i want to get married you know i'm
going to get married
and he said did you see her and he said
no
he said go see her because there's
something
in the eyes of the women of the ansar
you know
and other examples so you have to
see and here the issue of seeing
obviously is related to what is related
to
attraction which is again huge and taboo
a lot within our community so what
happens is
again i base it on you know 17 years of
counseling experience in the community
where the brother the guy
you know his mom picks the wife for him
kind of thing you know she says okay my
son
we have this family they're a good
family
and they are my friend and i've already
talked to the mom
and she has a daughter okay and
she's really good she's studying tatata
and
you gotta marry her because it's a good
family and we want to unite the two
families and you know the guy is a very
nice kid he's an obedient kid
he's going to say yes mom all right and
so there's something like the mothers
get involved in this a lot
from my experience in the community the
mothers do a lot of you know
going seeing it's like almost like the
mother is marrying the woman you know
like she has to be happy
i'm not going to name the cultures but
throughout there is
a you know you can say consistency in
this in this problem now
i don't want to generalize but yes this
is an issue so the guy accepts
sometimes even before seeing the girl or
even if he's going to see the girl
he's not going to be able to put an
argument up all right
okay really i don't like her some people
do when it's really
there's incompatibility full
incompatibility
but in general a lot of the i think the
way we raise our children
is is good that they are obedient to the
parents
but this is not the correct approach of
islam where like
it's just samia and alta anna for
everything with parents because parents
are not
allah right they can be wrong
and you i think the way a
man or a woman has to think when it
comes to obedience to parents
sorry let's use even stronger words when
the parents
push the marriage on them okay
and kind like don't give them any choice
i think the way
they have to understand is that okay i
will obey my parents and my parents
might be happy
now but within two years if things don't
work out
the consequences of my decision are
going to hurt my parents
are going to hurt me and are going to
hurt that woman
right so right now they might be happy
with me but you're not
thinking ahead right you're not thinking
ahead
and you might make a mistake and come on
let's be honest
um a lot of people do push themselves
onto the marriage and within a few years
they can't be together they just cannot
coexist in the same place
and they will divorce or if they do not
divorce and some cultures
obviously the issue of divorce is
against something very very taboo
so they they stick it out
and suffer right they suffer but it's a
very miserable
life and the families feel it because
there's
you know when you're like faking it and
you're just trying to get through it
you're not really you're not really
behaving well people notice you're not
giving the best there's no flow of
energy there's no flow right
you go to a family meeting people notice
like what's wrong with this person you
know
like they're not happy you can't hide
i'm so sorry
but happiness you cannot hide even if
you fake it you're the best person
right to fake it in the end people feel
that
it is fake so it's gonna hurt people
people are gonna start wondering
being sad what's wrong with you are you
okay you know pushing you
trying to get into your life and it's
just not good so vetting is just
so important on all levels the physical
level
you know the chemistry the
um psychological emotional spiritual
level the deen
islam make sure that you're connected
there all these aspects are very
important how are you going to know
whether you're going to be able to be
compatible
you have to meet you have to see each
other you have to interact
before uh you should marry the prophet
sallam
she knew a lot about him and not just
that he worked for her
and she asked about him she inquired
so that's we see now here a few steps
that we can be doing the vetting process
so number one yes you should
see the person and there should be some
proximity
not just a picture sorry you know but
pictures
today especially today with all these
filters you know people are living life
with the filter
so it's like good from far but far from
good
you know what i mean when you actually
see it in reality
so of course
forgive me any beauty is in the eye of
behold i understand i know some people
are like bro
what you're talking about right i'm
beautiful alhamdulillah inshallah you
are
but this is the reality right people
need to there has to be proximity this
is the way
humans have been dealing for thousands
of years
because when there's proximity there's
there's there's pheromones there's
energy there's
things that flows right and you you feel
it you know you feel when you're around
someone so how many times
you know you exchange messages whatsapp
this and that
but then when you get to meet that
person face to face it's a whole
different dynamics
all right and that's why i really don't
like the way our world is going and
where it's going
because we are removing the the
human element from the equation
when it comes to relationships business
dealings and so on
so go see her and you will feel it
now another problem is that a lot of
people say well
i'm not feeling it now but inshallah i
will feel it later
you know like this is something that i
heard that it's gonna come later
so you know it's okay i'll just accept
now
maybe maybe not
that you don't know you just don't know
right
so again that's why the processor did
tell us how about go
see he could have said oh don't worry
man just go ahead and talk allah and
you'll feel it after you know check it
out after no he said go
check it out make sure you're okay make
sure you're happy make sure you
feel good about it this is the person
you're going to wake up
next to the for the rest of life and you
want to make sure
you wake up happy so the prophet sam
said in authentic hadith
that the best woman that you want to
marry is the one that when you look at
her
you are pleased and when you command her
she obeys all right so these are two
aspects that he
salah sallam uh talked he also said in
another hadith
that about the the um
the woman who is fertile or warm
okay i know i we don't use otherwise but
basically the fertile loving
woman who wants to produce children who
wants to be intimate
how you can know that well there are a
few ways to know that of course
uh people not comfortable at this but
there are ways
you know allah has put a frame a general
framework within the sharia
and has made things very general like
for example in science right
and so on things in the quran general
that
um that push people encourage people to
explore
the natural sciences and the the
humanities and so on
so that's where we see the scholars of
old that this
general framework there's certain
specifics in islam for sure
and then there's general frameworks and
those
push you to explore more to learn more
within the
general you know demarcations of the
sharia
so we see these advice to the prophesy
so definitely are we following that
again my argument is always like are we
actually following islam
in anything so today we're talking about
intimacy okay vetting are we
actually following the sunnah and my
response will be no
i think we're following culture in a lot
of cases
and some of the culture with all the
respect because this
you know changes and so on some things
are just
extra you know i'm not trying to
disrespect anyone
that's i'm not naming but some things
are just extra and those extra
are causing the problems that we're
having today
so in someone's culture it's like you
know you don't have to see someone you
just see them on the day of your
marriage
i know some people get upset but then
again you are
setting yourself up for failure people
say yeah bro but look
we are you know we don't have divorce in
our community
yeah but people are suffering yes
they're sticking together but they're
committing zina
they're addicted to porn they're gay
they're this they're that
again i'm talking from from you know 100
from hundreds if not thousands of cases
that i deal with so i guess people stick
it out and yeah you don't have the
numbers the statistics that in our
community we have huge divorce but are
you happy
or it's not about being happy like you
who you know you're jumping up and down
it's about being content about
you know having flow about going through
your life and worshiping allah and
achieving things in life
because that's what happens when you
have a mental psychological emotional
block that comes out of a bad
negative toxic relationship you can't
give the world the best that you have
you might be very skilled you might have
good talents
and many things and to be honest you're
you're making uh
a dolm or a wrong doing to the world
because allah is giving you all the
skills and the world doesn't get it from
you know what i mean like i had i had
one main thing
on my mind what would you say um
it's like a good list of red flags of
women to avoid today
in the modern world from a man's side
uh in terms of women what to avoid
well i think the woman who complains a
lot if that's all she does in your
initial conversation just complains
about this
about that it's all about like you know
complaining be careful of a person who
nags and complaints
okay might be a beautiful person might
be a beautiful woman
but if she's always complaining and
nagging you know if her conversations
start well you know
my friend is like this and my family is
like that and my university is like this
and my
everything is about you know complaining
it's not a good
thing because shows a personality issue
that this person is prone to being you
know to complain a lot and that's
going to come to you i heard i heard
this i heard this quote
if she complains about you i'm sorry if
she complains to you about them
she's complaining to them about you
exactly exactly she's
feeble right now dude
so yeah i think that's that's probably
one of the the most important things and
again i as i said before like people um
and on the
on the guy side from the woman to the
guy
a big red flag if he's always like
i don't know we'll see like he's not
decisive right
if a woman is going to ask a man
questions when she vets him
she talks to him she meets him face to
face and he's like
not he doesn't have a plan he's just
like i don't know
we'll see insha allah you know inshallah
is
masha'allah you know something you know
that is very important our deen
but people use it like kind of like as a
substitute for i have no clue what i'm
doing
let's just see what happens you know
what i mean and that's not correct
so she should be very very wary of that
all right
um definitely physical attraction is
very important and you will feel it
okay people are not in touch with
themselves that's the problem i think
because they suppress their emotions and
we see this when we look in the
the poetry of the arabs um you know the
scholars and so on talking about love
for example and there is no suppression
of emotion
it's just control and management of how
you behave and what you do
in terms of you know the dynamics in
society the respect that you have for
each other
but there was never a blockage of
emotions and of
feelings and um
even the prophet sallam he he uh you
know tells a story
of some of the you know some of the uh
old
pre-islamic you know incidents about
love and about
this and that so and has a discussion
with his wife with the aisha
or the allah and sometimes they're
joking about marriage and this and that
so there was no like you know a
repression repression of emotions but we
find that that happens
in our communities so people go with
these like
you know these these these blocks and
they don't want to feel anything they
don't want to
see how they feel they don't know how to
check whether they feel something or not
and you know then someone asked him so
what do you think are you okay
like it's okay i guess i don't know
bismillah you know may allah help it
make it easy and then they go ahead and
again
marriage might end up in problems all
right so they have you have to go
to the vetting session one twice
three times four times i don't know ten
times till you are happy
now again the setting and how and all
that should be respectful should be with
the knowledge of people
within public this no doubt but not just
like yeah
uh auntie wreck you know uh recommended
a girl
calls the mom mom sets it up okay nikkah
is on the 20th you know of this month
let's do it you know what i mean okay
it's not
so good and then you know two years
later they're in our office you know or
in one of our files
dealing with you know so many issues
right or divorcing or
any other problems so i think this is
very
important brother says i cannot
emphasize enough that there has to be
something
don't go like it's not dating or you
know go for two years let me get to know
this person let me taste the
cake and you know and all that no but
there has to be
some form of of you know of vetting
and as we said last time i mean these
two points i said is
like you ask allah right you have to
learn it's taharah some people don't
know
you consult with people and you ask
around like it's not just your vetting
that's another
wave or another form of wedding is that
you
ask people do your homework ask people
who know them families this and that
don't just okay i met them because this
person can put in a very nice
a very nice image when they meet you
they might be
very very good when they meet you
obviously going to be on their best
behavior right because they're already
primed you know when i go and inspect
teachers um in in schools
as an inspector i do
announce inspections then i do
unannounced inspections because you know
announced inspections everyone's going
to prepare right like they know they're
going to put on their best i used to
when i used to be a teacher i used to
have my ace
lesson up my sleeve you know like it was
just ready whenever an inspection comes
it's like i used to you know
have like the best lesson ready so i
kind of beat the
the un uh the unannounced inspection
like that i would pull out the best
lesson ever
but i try to go and not catch them but i
want to see how you are in
in just your regular day-to-day how you
behave that's why i one of the sub if i
remember the story correctly
that he was hiding he was checking
this woman out and looking and see but
he was kind of like hiding not
allowing her to see him and he told the
prosecutor he was laughing you know
so he was like kind of like just i want
to say spying but he was like just you
know
just checking it out and just seeing uh
just to see how she acts naturally
you know and that's how it is right if
someone sees you
but if if you're on your own on your own
terms you you act differently right so
it's important
to know that's why um the sahabah said
that you only know a person truly when
you live with them
when you travel with them when you make
business with them right
these are this is a reality and that's
the reality that
in the end even this person you read
them and whatnot you're only gonna find
out who they really are
within the first few you know months or
first year
of living with them and you have to make
adjustments and whatnot but
vetting just to leave it to to end the
point
is extremely important i believe our
community doesn't do enough i believe
the
the community needs to set up classes
to teach people how to go about it okay
pre-marital
counseling it is now part of some of the
masajid i believe and some of the
programs that they have alhamdulillah
i think it is increasing but it's it
needs to be done
more it needs to be done more and i'm
not sure i've seen some of the courses i
think needs to be a bit more realistic
and a bit more not just about okay your
rights in islam are this and her rights
are that okay get married no it's about
like
what are the some of the things that you
can do some things you can ask
some of the issues you can you know you
can consider
and whatnot and again based on as we got
went right now
on the quran sun now what the prophesym
did let's look at the marriage of the
sahaba
because again we might have a standard i
was listening to a lecture the other day
these uh these sisters were talking
about you know
marriage but the problem is their
standard was was their own experiences
only
it was not the quran it was not examples
from the life of the process
they're just giving their own
experiences and opinions
and that's not necessarily the best so i
think we need to
contextualize things and give the
evidence because
in the end this is the best revelation
this is the revelation from allah
and we want to make sure that we
understand it and we use
those concepts to apply to our daily
life so very important to have
pre-marital classes get the people out
there let them see each other put them
face to
face let them ask the questions
build scenarios have a list like sit
down have a paper and build
10 scenarios that you think in life are
important
that would really tick you off like if
you know if it happens in the wrong way
like something that's really
you know it's like you cringe you know
when it happens in life
and then set it up in such a way and
then ask the sister like someone like
what would you do if
if i come home and this you know
something like that you know
like i don't know one important question
is like what would you do if you come
home
at you know 8 9 p.m and you're tired
and i want to get busy you know i want
to go to bed you know i want to have
i want to be intimate you know what
would you say and you know like no
you know it's like i think that's like
not you know not a problem
we already did last night
something like that again you know like
you gotta understand some of these
issues yeah it's not always not sad you
know you gotta understand
you know uh some of these things i know
man
quick reminder bro you gotta leave soon
yeah no i'm about to leave right now i
was about to say
everything what are you cooking you i'm
about to cook some
beef with some potatoes and some chicken
and i'm gonna have to guess kills
man i got to brian got no wives oh
so like what are you doing i got a wife
or something and
cooking are you black belt in cooking
i'm like i'm like a white belt bro am i
cooking
sometimes i'll cook i'll be like oh this
is nice and i'll go to a restaurant like
yeah
nah my cooking ain't good but it's like
nice when you do it right like it's like
you feel like clean
clean yeah i'd rather be doing something
else
yeah it's just a time man yeah yeah yeah
but bro the last thing that i want to
say is that it's very logical
what you're saying i mean someone in the
right mind wouldn't just go and get
married
with another person without knowing this
person
whether they're muslim or not you know
so i think i think it's beautiful that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
is saying this
and it's also pure logic like someone
can
comprehend this without even knowing
islam
without knowing anything of it what up
hold up
did you just say the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
i did that they came out clean right in
my opinion i
it's getting kind of dark here i'm gonna
head out
yes sir
yeah um with that being said all the red
flags aside
um what are some green ones right um i
do a lot of online coaching
you know fitness type of stuff but
people coming with questions on marriage
you know just normal type of
relationship stuff uh
you know just mental health stuff too
and then one of the most common things i
have
once we're done red flags is what are
some green flags
or green lights right things that are
like standards
things that you will know without these
you will not
for example consider even someone so
what would that be for you brother
yeah i think um you know for a woman if
i look at a woman if i meet a woman
to to marry her one of the most
important things
would be of course as the prophet sallam
said look at her dean you know the deen
first right
and i think when you look at the dean uh
be careful
here and i've made a video on this about
marrying the sheikha you know
don't be deceived a lot of guys get
deceived by the
appearance and the some of the practice
so you know mashallah the hijab is good
the niqab or so on which is very
important no doubt
i mean that's something important but a
lot of times guys prematurely think that
okay she's really wearing an abaya
and nikob so she must be like a really
really good muslim
okay a good muslim has a very
comprehensive term
and i think the brothers because of the
a lot of the issues that are addressed
in the social media
muslim discourse is a lot about to do
with
the prayer the appearance to this that
right
so a lot of people make the judgment
like she must be a good muslim because
she wears niqab
not necessarily okay not necessarily you
have to be careful and that's why i said
in my video
some of the guys suffer they've married
the nikabi they married the very you
know
pious looking everything but she's not a
good wife
you understand so for example she'll be
praying
late so praying the whole night you know
and
a lot of yeah they do like you know
reading quran a lot studying and so on
but when he calls her to bed she says no
okay she says i don't want to make gosul
for example it was one of the questions
that came you know i don't like to make
hustle
so can i just reject you know intimacy
because you know i want to
do this and do that no that's that's
that's
misunderstood actually that is a problem
in her
fick and in islam
means understanding deen
he will understand or be thought to
understand in the deen
so if she's putting
which is a sunna over her husband who
calls her to bed which is a fard
she has misunderstood the priorities of
islam
and i can tell you that that that
marriage is going to fall apart she is
praying and she was going to say
something like
but i'm praying i'm making dua for you
oh
i'm suffering you know what i mean like
i need i need to be intimate
and you know she's gonna but i'm fasting
but i'm studying islam i thought you're
gonna be happy
i want to raise our children islam yeah
good you don't have to be
uh you know a mufti you know what i mean
you don't have to become a scholar
you know what i mean i'm not saying that
some women should not become a scholar
but in general
that is not something that is by default
that women should take upon what do you
what do you say about this this thing
that all women say nowadays including
muslim feminists
yeah is it only about that is it is it
all about intimacy
what do you say to that well i'll say
what the sheikh uh
sheikh uh one of the shaykhs i'm not
gonna name me because i don't want
people to
smash his inbox but when he was asked
that question he said yes
yes he said it is indeed is one of the
most important thing in nikah
that becomes the first thing that
becomes halal when you
uh marry is intimacy right that's why
it's called nika so very important
it's not the only thing no but when it's
not there then
definitely is going to be the one thing
that's always on the mind you know and
it's going to cause
problems so um
she cannot use that he's going to suffer
and she's going to suffer too it depends
obviously and that's the issue right of
feeling
the connection the issues of libido and
differences in that that's also a
problem
that needs to be discussed at some point
but definitely um
she you know she can be very religious
looking
praying practicing but all these things
are sunnah the procession said
the muslim woman she just has to do her
fardh and let's analyze that
means she prays five daily prayers no
extra sunnah
fart means no of course you'll pray
sunnah but in general that's all it's
near her fat
five daily prayers okay fasting ramadan
perfect okay
what else believing in allah and his
messenger okay three are there are five
uh fulfilling hajj
if he has if she has the ability if not
then
you know so then it's only three now you
have and to pay zakah
again if the nisab is met so even that
you don't know right so basically she
has to do three things okay to believe
in allah is messenger
to pray and to fast and obey her husband
she can choose whichever gate of jannah
she will walk through and that's my
question to the sisters
do you want jannah shortcut is there
shortcut
is there you wanna struggle and be in
the spotlight and on the podiums and
giving lectures and
empowering women and all that and
struggling your way
dunya and divorcing and going because
you think you have your rights and you
have to lift your fist in the air
and you think you're going to get to
jenna i'm not i'm not stuffed the one
who decides
i'm just saying that it's quite i can
see the women exhausting themselves
they can see wind and being tired yes
wasn't there a hadith where uh
a guy came up to the prophet sallam and
i think i don't know if it was one of
the sahaba but he was
he was like uh you know should i cross
straight to you and
the result of someone was saying if
there was someone that i could tell you
to prosper to aside from allah it would
be to your husbands
women to their husband yeah so he came
from from the christian lands and he saw
some people doing that to their priest
and whatnot
so he wanted to do that he actually did
that and salsem said no you cannot do
that he says
but if anyone would have been ordered to
it would have been the woman towards the
men because of the responsibility and
accountability that the man has
you know and the father that allah has
given him right a lot of people
misinterpret this they think that it's
like oh look at this male chauvinist you
it's so sad like i've seen these days
now these liberal sisters
are have no limits like they are they're
questioning the scholarship of islam
saying that it's the man that you know
twisted these hadith and this and that
and
back you know mouthing bugatti and
muslim and the scholars of islam and
it's very sad that it reached to this
position but it is a
reality so yeah i mean that's that's
that's the shortcut women have the
shortcut that doesn't mean they cannot
be happy they cannot do things that
doesn't mean they're
slave that doesn't mean no that's not
what i'm talking about the mindset
i'm talking about you know the problem
is with our sisters today that they
don't accept
the belief so their mindset is clogged
so of course they're going to see it as
negative they're going to say there's
something difficult for them harsh
it's all about us but when you have
faith and iman
and you understand the context of this
and you don't see i'm not stuck i'm not
a slave i'm humble i'm happy i'm you
know
because i understand what's my objective
my objective is janna this life is very
short
i can still enjoy this life i will enjoy
this life because my husband is happy
with me
and i'm happy with him and we love each
other and i do my part he does his part
we're a team
we have beautiful children i don't need
to listen to this feminist rant that go
out there
and beat yourself in the chest and you
know make your hijab into a turban and
take it off and
burn it and be strong and you know talk
about your
problems and this and that you know and
then
i get jenna right so i don't know it's
it's um it's a problem
i think a lot of women are very happy
with just
following the quran sunnah because their
mindset is tuned
to that and if a sister comes and says
but you're oppressed
like i was just talking to a to a
brother yesterday
and he said that people he's a
traditional brother
and he says my family he says my own
family
are attacking my wife because she's like
happy to cook for me every day and
they're saying well you're
you're oppressing her and they're coming
to her and saying you are oppressed and
she says
no i'm not no no you are oppressed she's
like but i'm
not i'm enjoying what i'm doing i'm
happy no no no you just
brainwash you don't understand you're
gonna see the way we see it you're gonna
see
and she's like i don't see it i'm very
happy with my husband he's very happy
with me
i enjoy what i'm doing what is your
problem you know what i mean like what's
wrong with you like leave me to myself
man like take it easy you know
it's it's the mindset man it's the
mindset has been attacked
of course by the propaganda and the
enemies of islam and it changes right
because
belief changes believe is can be
changed so these are i would say a very
important things
uh for for brothers to to make sure that
when they
choose the dean that it includes
her understanding of priorities of the
fudd
of her position as a wife and
yeah i mean not every mostly men are not
looking for scholar women they're
looking for
good wives good mothers who have their
deen and no they're dean i'm not saying
you know to be ignorant actually
it's important the process means to
educate the women it's important
we're not saying we're not saying that
no no education
no but they should understand their
priorities and it is part of the fick
at this part of the teachings
of islam it's very very important that
is a very important green flag for me
too and so i can ask the right question
so
i'm not going to ask her like okay what
is the nisab of you know
of zakka or this or that you know that's
not gonna be my question to be honest
because then you can look up
i will ask her issues around application
in marriage and being a mother the fick
of muammar or dealings with each other
okay this is very important how this
that
and so on you know how would you deal
with the neighbors how would you deal
with me
you know these kind of stuff and these
bro
i'm learning so much but this is one
thing i need to add that
these things naturally women want to
talk about and they'll be honest
if you have some level of not being
judgmental
now i'm not saying you need to be
non-judgmental just to get her to you
know
read everything out but it's like you
shouldn't be too judgmental anyway
especially with a woman that you're not
even gonna marry
if she says something that's a complete
deal breaking red flag you don't need to
marry her
but at least you'll get to know her
fully it's better to know that
woman fully and not marry her then not
know her at all and then get into a
marriage with her and then find out
later on
oh what is this i didn't think you were
like this you wore hijab uh your sister
i thought it was this and come on like
that's gonna end
um rami do feel free to jump in right
now
anytime um because you've been a little
i don't know if uh we're stealing the
mic too much but we're on a time crunch
not too much there's we talked about it
from a man's side
i want to know things from a woman's
side so what are things
that you know how can a woman know that
i have an effeminate
man who's obviously not you know good
marriage material
by the least um because you talked about
decisiveness so that's one
yes once that's done um let's skip over
to what parents can do any advice you
have for parents
on their kids that are ready for
marriage and how they can approach that
cool yeah so from the women's side uh
we're going again maybe sister would be
like how did you know you're a guy you
know because again i deal with a lot of
female clients
okay and people can judge whatever many
of the sheikhs respond to sisters and
you know i can name them but again
people again are judgmental
uh we have our system and our way and we
do it properly and we've been doing it
for a long time
um and with with women
you know guys uh because of the system
of the 21st century starting with the
educational system
uh the just the way they they're
they're you know raised up by the media
and so on guys are quite weak today we
have to admit that
okay i know that we we are trying to
empower men and to raise you know the
awareness of masculinity
but part of that is realizing where we
are right so when you
try to revamp a system you do what's
called a baseline assessment so when we
do a baseline assessment of men today
men are i mean they leave a lot to be
wished for you know what i mean they
are weak spiritually emotionally
intellectually
financially physically we
are weak just look around go to the
masjid and just take a simple
something i guess that i was praying
just before juma we went early
and i i do this because as a you know
person who comes from science background
i do i observe so i was sitting around
and just looking at the
the size of people sorry you know i
don't want to be you know but it was
just the size of people
and it was something i was like how many
in that
masjid it was about i estimated about
400 people there was about
you know five they were in shape okay
only
five they were in shape the other ones
sadly
sadly you know it was it was just
something exciting like you're judging
you know i'm not judging i'm just trying
to make a point
okay um the prophet sallam made very
clear only the guy came with a you know
with the belly
uh the sahaba were you don't have to
have an eight pack guys that's not what
i'm talking not beach body you know ab
whatever i don't know what you know
men's health thing you know
that's not what i'm talking if you can
do it hamdi labs i mean i'm sure maybe
your your wife would like that
but if you don't take care of your
self it shows again mindset and
character that you don't care about
yourself
all right you can tell a lot about a man
when you look at the way he looks he
takes
himself his clothes his car
okay if it's clean or not a lot of
things okay there's room
uh a lot of things you can tell a lot
about
amen and sadly men today are quite weak
so when women
they want to vet and they want to see
what i choose you want to look for a man
who is strong
okay as the prophet said a muslim
life that the strong muslim is more
beloved to allah than the weak
muslim right now you'll be like oh again
you're focusing on this
no i'm saying what the promise of said
and it's all over it's not just about
that he has muscles or not that's not
what i'm saying i'm saying
his character is he decisive does he
have a plan in life ask
him sisters just go like okay brother i
like you you know
you're handsome talk let's get married
nah
ask him what's your plan in life what do
you want to do
what is your goal how are you going to
take care of us uh
what do you you know ask these questions
about plans
about their dreams it's not there's a
difference
be careful usually people ask about what
job right do you have a job what do you
work
as no man because that job can disappear
in no time
okay and that job might might not be
ask them about what is their
personal goal in life their objective
their you know mission and vision
it's not the job guys it's not the job
because you see
that person when he has a mission and
vision
the job will be just a sub up a
means to reach that okay
so that woman will know that this guy he
will do whatever it takes
okay whatever it takes including work
two jobs and he's not gonna feel ashamed
because he's gonna understand
that that's not about a career it's
about a
means for him to achieve what he wants
to do and he'll do anything to achieve
that goal
and if you share that dream and if you
believe in him then that is a good man
to rely upon because he's not going to
leave you
at the first sign of of you know
problems or financial difficulties or
he's going to run away from
responsibility he's going to be able to
stick about him you know we know
it's been proven that women prefer
and really react well to stability to
safety
it's just the way allah created them
right and that's
another um evidence for the fact that
you know women's
role is not to be out there and about
there and doing all the things that
meant
they're more of the nurture they're more
of the
one who built the home and the family
and managed that
all right and the man is the one who's
doing hustling right and the two again
are a team
and when the dynamics are clear
alhamdulillah the marriage is really
good right because imagine
the husband is out she's taking care of
things
he they miss each other they come you
know but
if both of them are out both of them are
doing things
both of them have their own life both
are tired they just come home and just
cohabitate there's like
roommates you know what i mean that's
not that's not marriage man
and that's the thing right it's like i'm
telling you if a woman comes home
tired okay and we're talking about
intimacy
forget about intimacy bro it ain't
happening if she's not in the mood the
mindset is not there
okay she's just not happening and that's
just the way women are again i'm not
generalizing there might be exceptions
some sister watching i'm like i'm not
like that i can do anytime
no but in general if she's very tired
her
you know she had a bad day her boss was
being you know a
bad guy or whatever or she's you know
the
whatever there was problems at work she
has the wrong mindset
right now wrong emotions gets home stuck
in traffic for an hour
you know she's not going to want to do
it man even if she's going to force
herself
it's not going to be good you're going
to feel that you are
she's not there she's not present okay
and you're gonna feel it
you're not gonna like it all right um
but if she's home she's taking care of
things she has time she relaxes she does
a few things chores
kids that it's like you know it's she's
in her zone she's feminine
you're coming home from a long day bro
like 9
10 12 hours having to put up with all
kinds of dudes and this and that you
know
people being rude guy cut you off this
and that you're super
like tense upset whatnot
bro you walk through that door and you
see your princess bro it's like
nothing happened nothing and she comes
and gives you a hug and says
let's go you're ready bro it's like what
you know it's like
just boom you just that's how the men
are we're go
we can be in the lowest level man and
you see your woman
beautiful ready for you and she just
says the right thing or touches you in
the right way or gives you the hug she
smells good
and it's like it's morning seven a.m i'm
ready you know it's like nothing
happened
all the 12 hours are erased and you're
good to go man and it will be amazing
and then you can really relax you know
you're like chilling man like you can go
to sleep
but if not you're going to be thinking
that that reset doesn't happen
you're going to be thinking about that
10 hours that happened you can't even
fall asleep
men are complaining they don't get
enough sleep quality sleep
yeah because this is great to be
intimate and then go to sleep after you
know you relax
take it easy masha'allah you know but if
both of you are out there man forget
about
imagine coming home from along the work
and she just adds more to your plate
not the literal plate like i'm not
talking dinner i'm talking about just
more stuff to deal with and it's just
like come on
yeah it's not it doesn't work man yeah
it's it's a man
you know man gets stressed man gets
stressed
100 romney you got any comments bro we
got two minutes left
no honestly i'm just listening in i'm
like that's facts masha allah
mm-hmm so
yeah i mean uh i think we even we can
talk more about this even the next
episode there's still
a lot that we can discuss i think we
should prematurely leave it because
there's
we want to make sure this series really
address this i think
again to restate the objective of the
series to our
viewers you know this is the the real
the realest podcast in the dunya i mean
because we're like
talking about things that people don't
talk but they're problems these are
issues right so the objective is to get
come up with some solutions change the
mindset of people
and again we're not saying because when
i talk about
intimacy a lot of people attack and say
this is like shameful and it's not
that's not we're trying to be rated art
on that already
sorry we're trying to to raise an issue
and give some solutions to a big problem
that is
breaking the ummah is breaking the
marriages right breaking the family
which is the building block
of the umm so we want to give some
solutions change the mindset not be
vulgar or bad or this or that
i mean what a final what a wonderful
note man any last uh comments from
either of you
no all right then we'll pick this up
tomorrow inshaallah you guys enjoy
your iftar inshallah
yeah all good if you made it this far
hashtag
pick the right one picked her out
and make sure they checked the previous
ones and the previous episodes as well
thanks 100 yes yes if i wasn't so sloppy
i would have
i remembered to put that in but uh
i apologize for the bummy intro but i
shall like and have a better outro insha
allah
uh may allah accept from us uh the
series and in
our fasting and and bless us with the
month of ramadan i mean
that being said may allah bless you all
a lot of people have this misconception
that uh you know once i feel closer to
god then i'm going to start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith where he says that the
most beloved acts of worship to god are
those which he made obligatory
the person continues to get closer and
closer to allah key point gets closer
and closer by voluntary acts of good
so like certain uh um things you know
for the sake of allah things that are
not obligatory but you do them just to
please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
allah you want allah to love you
do what allah prescribes for you which
is
so praying fasting
and then on top of that sunnah prayers
uh suddenly fasts
giving extra charity to the point where
allah will insha allah begin to love you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
me